and nora is in houston where as you know
the rain is still coming down up to 15
inches more is in the forecast today as
harvey intensifies and takes aim for a
second landfall on the gulf coast
yeah good morning to you gail that's
right it's not clear how many people are
still trapped inside their homes about
four days after the storm hit we've seen
volunteers stepping up their efforts to
bring neighbors to safety when first
responders aren't available david
begneau has been following some of those
citizen heroes that you were just
talking about now he is now on a flooded
highway just south of houston david good
morning
noor good morning this is state highway
288 underwater
you cannot imagine the detours that
there are in the city of houston right
now first responders it can take an hour
or two hours just to get to people in
need folks are turning to social media
to beg for help knowing that civilian
rescuers may be their only option i've
even gotten tweets from people in out of
state who are saying hey i know you're
there reporting can you go check on this
loved one who i haven't spoken to since
saturday civilian rescuers have been
doing incredible work and this morning
we give credit where it's due
calls for help are echoing across
houston where do they need help civilian
samaritans like truett allen were
directed to this home in houston's
fleetwood neighborhood do you think it's
going to go upstairs
we were with them when they found laura
blenton she was nearly up to her knees
in flood water do you regret not leaving
sooner
yes
i should have susie russell and her
husband dale were awake all night they
were piling up furniture as the water
poured into their home
we didn't know what how high it would
get so it was concern of get what you
can people are using jet skis canoes
even inner tubes mattresses to bring
those stranded to drier ground john abel
is traveling from louisiana he wants to
assist with the rescue effort it's going
to be bad we've already
talked about that and prayed over
at this hotel crews arrived with high
water vehicles and boats to evacuate
people inside
strangers lined up their cars and trucks
on a nearby highway ready to take anyone
to safety we don't have anything
you know we lost everything in our
apartment
it's just really unfortunate
these evacuees are at the mercy of a
situation that is beyond their control i
can't even tell you anything what i can
tell you is that i can get you to a
place where you're going to have dry
clothes food
and you'll have a place to sleep for
tonight if you want to come with me we
can get you there
and then we can worry about what you're
trying to get to tomorrow
you know the evacuees are having to
worry about looters in nearby fort bend
county apparently looters are
impersonating first responders telling
folks to evacuate their home and then
going in and stealing from them nor the
houston police chief was quoted as
saying to the losers out there don't
come to houston and victimize our people
yeah there's a saying here as you know
david don't mess with texas the police
will come and get you thank you you got
it